how's it going everybody it's Warren and
it has been a long time since I've done
a DC video due to the fact that the
Avengers endgame hype is very real right
now however we just got a new trailer
for The Joker movie with joaquin phoenix
and it looks really really good
it's very evident that this is a very
different take on the Joker that we've
seen recently such as Jared Leto's the
Joker
this movie is supposed to be a tragedy
when it was pitched to the studio it was
pitched as a tragedy and that is
definitely what we see in this trailer
The Joker's character in the movie is
named Arthur Fleck and in this trailer
we see a series of very unfortunate
events happen to arthur Fleck we see
tragedy after tragedy ultimately leading
him to his breaking point
until we eventually see him become the
Joker at the end the Joker in this movie
is very real it's not over-the-top like
Jared Leto's Joker in Suicide Squad
other flick is a person who has a mental
illness who is just trying to take care
was mom who seems like she may have a
mental illness as well he's trying to
make ends meet working a job that he
hates as a clown spinning a sign outside
of the business while simultaneously
trying to make it as a comedian as well
it starts of course with an opening
scene on Gotham City this movie is
supposed to take place somewhere around
the 1970s timeline which was actually a
real rough time for New York in the
1970s so they're sort of carrying over
that vibe in this trailer for the Joker
in Gotham City we start by seeing Arthur
Fleck talked to a social worker where
she asks him does it help to have
someone to talk to if you freeze-frame
this scene right here and you zoom in on
her badge we can see that it says she
works for the Department of Health and
that her name is Deborah Kane Deborah
Kane is from the Batman novel the
ultimate evil she is a social worker in
the novel but she's also actually an
informant for Bruce Wayne and she
actually helps him take down a criminal
organization in the novel it's unclear
if she'll play a significant role in the
movie or if this is just an easter egg
the throwing in there we see him walk
through Gotham and then we see him walk
up a very large staircase very defeated
and very down on his luck which we'll
come back to later on in the video we
see him taking care of his mom and
probably see the only time where he has
genuine laughter and happiness in this
trailer we hear him say over this
footage my mother always tells me to
smile and put on a happy face she told
me I had a purpose to bring laughter and
joy into the world as he says this we
see him writing in a notebook or journal
with the title jokes and the top part
starts as kind of dark and twisted jokes
talking about the old people and
insomnia and the poor being confused but
on the bottom we can see him actually
writing about his own mental illness
that he suffers from and he's writing
his thoughts about it and it says the
worst part of having a mental illness is
people expect you to behave as if you
don't and this is where we start to see
the real struggles that Arthur Fleck is
having in his life because in the next
scene we see him spinning a sign for a
business that is about to go out of
business you can see the sign says
everything must go but he does have a
smile on his face and this goes back to
what his mother told him to do put on a
happy face and bring joy to the world so
he's doing the best he can he's about to
be out of a job but still trying to be
happy about it and then some kids come
and steal a sign he chases them into the
alleyway and they smash it on his face
and this is where we sort of start to
see the very dark side of this movie we
hear him say is it just me or is it
getting even crazier out there referring
to Gotham City with this line and then
we can see how his body is very decrepit
it's almost deformed
he's very poor in this movie he has a
mental illness and he probably doesn't
eat nearly enough what he needs to then
we have a scene with him and Sophie du
monde in a diner sophie is supposed to
be either his friend or his love
interest in the movie she smiles at him
and he smiles back but it almost seems
like he's forcing the smile as we know
this movie is supposed to be a series of
tragedies and based off what we've seen
in this trailer this relationship goes
bad and then things get even darker when
we see him go to the Arkham State
Hospital and notice that it doesn't say
Arkham Asylum its Arkham state hospital
it's not Arkham Asylum yet in this movie
Batman Bruce Wayne is still just only a
kid in fact we see young Bruce Wayne in
this trailer when he's in the elevator
and the mental patient is freaking out
if you look on the back wall you can
actually see some green letters with a
green question mark this could be a
little Easter Egg referencing the
Riddler possibly setting him up for
future movies so we see him inside the
state hospital where he's talking to
somebody that works there behind the
cage and it looks like he's getting some
pretty bad news you can tell by the way
that he asked the person what that they
have some sort of bad news for him it
could be news that his mother has
actually died because she has a mental
illness and at some point she could end
up stayin in the Arkham state hospital
so this scene could be him going to
visit her but he finds out and gets the
news that his mother has died and from
here we just see Arthur Fleck spiral out
of
control until he eventually becomes the
Joker we see him into stand-up comedy
club and we get our first Joker laugh
and I must say that this laugh is creepy
but I love it I don't think it's
over-the-top I think it's a very real
crazy laugh and then again from here we
just see him sort of spiral out of
control and lose his mind we have this
scene where he's here getting ready for
work and he forces himself literally to
put a smile on his face we see him
laughing and crying on the train trying
to force himself to be happy even though
he's really really depressed in its life
and then these guys in the Train beat
him up we see him dancing around a
little bit and then we see him look into
the mirror and it looks like this is the
moment where he embraces himself as the
Joker from here on out in the movie it
looks like he goes into full Joker mode
kind of like he's given up and he just
doesn't care anymore
we see that he has a gun in his hand and
he's dancing around with the gun in his
hand like he just did something with it
like he just shot somebody and at the
same time we hear Thomas Waynes voice
and we see him on the TV this is of
course Bruce Wayne Batman's father we
hear him say what kind of coward would
do something that cold-blooded somebody
who hides behind a mask so it seems like
Arthur Fleck finally hit his snapping
point put on his mask put on his Joker
outfit went and he killed somebody and
now Bruce Wayne is talking about that
publicly we see a cop chasing him on the
subway and we actually don't know who
this character is yet a character has
not been listed for this actor yet but
it is widely believed that this is Jim
Gordon the next scene is actually the
Joker at Wayne Manor with Bruce Wayne as
you can see Bruce Wayne is just a child
when these events take place but they're
already setting up some weird dynamic
between the two of them because the
Joker sticks his fingers in his mouth
makes him smile and it's interesting
because it seems like the antagonist of
this movie is actually going to be
Thomas Wayne Bruce Wayne's father and
spoiler alert we all know Batman's past
right we know how his parents died so
they could be doing a little bit of
retconning maybe the Joker will end up
killing Batman's parents from here on
out we see several scenes of him going
crazy and he starts to kind of sink into
the Joker he's becoming the Joker he's
looking at himself in the mirror and he
can't stand the sight of himself so he
bashes his head into the mirror but he's
clearly gotten attention since he's
become the Joker because he's going onto
Late Show hosted by Murray Franklin who
was Robert
Aeros character so he's clearly up to a
lot as the Joker and he seems to be
getting some followers too because we
see these protesters all wearing the
Joker's mask fighting the cops we get a
few more shots of them becoming even
crazier becoming the Joker even more and
we hear him say I used to think that my
life was a tragedy but now I realize
it's a comedy this is who the Joker is
somebody with a very tragic backstory
with a mental illness who eventually
just goes insane the origin of the Joker
isn't actually really known either this
is why in the dark night we hear Heath
Ledger actually say two different
backstories for how he got his scars
he's actually referencing two different
origins from the comics because again
there isn't one clear origin for the
Joker in the comics so now we see him in
his full Joker suit he's walking down
the hallway of the apartment very
confidently carrying flowers in his hand
most likely going to see Sophie or if
his mother's alive his mother we then
see him basically dancing on the same
stairs that we saw him in the beginning
where he was really beaten up and they
put this at the very end of the trailer
because in the very beginning we saw him
down on his luck and we saw this whole
tragedy play out throughout this trailer
to lead him to becoming the Joker and
then of course we end with a scene with
the Joker and full makeup full outfit in
the elevator and right before it closes
he gives us a little Joker smile so
that's it for my breakdown of the new
Joker trailer that we got today let me
know what you thought about the trailer
and do you like the way Joaquin Phoenix
betrayed the Joker let me know in the
comments down below and just a reminder
I'm still doing my giveaway giving away
a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet if you'd
like to interfere your chance to win all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain and also
be sure to subscribe if you want to stay
up-to-date on movies like the Joker
Avengers in game and all things relating
to superheroes as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]